hey youtubers is Charlie so for my Game
of Thrones bonus video this week I'm
going to talk all about Brendan rivers
the Bloodraven you also probably know
him as the three-eyed Raven just careful
for spoilers for everything that's
happened on the show so far and there is
a new round of the giveaway that starts
now all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so in case you missed the news
earlier this year max von sydow has been
recast as the three-eyed Raven that
person that's helping train bran
underneath the giant weirwood why did
they recast the character if they
already had somebody at then - season 4
well there's a number of reasons the
Game of Thrones recast roles 1 the actor
that played the character previously
isn't available because they did
something crazy where they passed away
or they're too ill or 2 they've expanded
the part and they need someone that they
feel like is a stronger actor my guess
is is that we're going to see a whole
lot of three-eyed Raven scenes and
there's going to be a big speaking part
so they wanted to get a much bigger
actor enter Max von Sydow now I know I
put up this mean picture but that
doesn't necessarily mean that the
character is evil there's definitely a
lot of book theories about where the
three-eyed Ravens allegiance lives to
the great other to the red God to the
old gods technically then being green
seers I would think that their loyalty
is to the old gods
now the three-eyed Raven has had a bunch
of different names he lived a very long
life as a mortal man for the largest
part of his life like this last big
chunk he's been living as a three-eyed
raven though he was born the bastard
Brynden rivers to melissa Blackwood and
Aegon Targaryen the fourth that was the
Targaryen that had six mistresses a
whole bunch of bastards that sparked the
first Blackfyre rebellion
so just placing him in the timeline with
other big characters that martin has
written stories about he predates Duncan
egg but even though he's around doing
things in Westeros during the time
Dunkin eggs story is happening
they don't really cross paths like he's
not really part of those stories the
Duncan eggs stories mostly just follow
dunk and egg and the people that they
interact with now later in life he went
to the wall became Lord Commander then
became the three-eyed Raven but for the
earliest part of his life he was only
known as Brynden rivers the reason he's
called the Bloodraven is because as a
child he was born with this birthmark
over his face even though he was a great
warrior he kind of opted for more
scholarly pursuits so he gained powers
of magic like he gained the power to
glamour himself you know
make himself look like other people
think of him as being like a combination
of Samwell and his younger brother like
very studious but also a very good
warrior so the first big saga of his
life is the Blackfyre rebellion I've
already done a video about that so I'll
put a link in the description the
bastard that started the Blackfyre
rebellion was daemon Blackfyre Brendan's
half-brother by another woman there's
always a lot of resentment when it comes
to bastards especially when a king has a
number of sons he's always going to
favor one son more than the other so
Brendan Rivers was one of those more
favorite sons so Aegon the fourth gave a
Valyrian blade dark sister to burn in
rivers dark sister was the Valyrian
blade that originally belonged to
visenya targaryen she is one of the
sister wives of Aegon the first egg on
the conquer he also gave the sword of
succession the black fire ancestral
Valyrian blade to daemon waters not to
his legitimate heir that he had with his
wife all kinds of resentment and drama
amongst all the brothers bastards and
legitimate and for those that are asking
the whereabouts of dark sister are still
unknown
like like bittersteel took black fire
the ancestral Targaryen blade the other
big Valyrian blade but later in life
when Brynden rivers went to the wall
nobody knows if he took dark sister with
them so the blades whereabouts are
completely unknown
wouldn't it be cool though if it's
somewhere underneath that weirwood there
there might be a Valyrian blade
somewhere nearby so keep your eyes
peeled
the second big era in his life was when
he served as hand of the King to
multiple Targaryen Kings and the person
to name him hand of the king wasn't
originally the brother that he sided
with during the Blackfyre rebellion but
he did serve on that brothers small
council so you can look at it as a
reward for siding with the crown like
hey you sided with us instead of siding
with the black fire so we're going to
name you to the small Council that's our
garyun King died his successor became
heiress the first that person was the
one to name him hand of the king maker
the first eventually became king he
served through his reign then when he
died Brynden rivers acting as hand of
the king called a great council to
decide who should be the next king there
was this big issue of succession
eventually Aegon v was chosen now we
know him as egg from the duck and egg
series so like little egg here was Aegon
v because of some shadiness that
happened at that Great Council Aegon v
egg had Brynden rivers imprisoned and
thrown in the black cells what happened
is
black fires were still a big thing in
the east and they wanted to treat
peacefully with the crown like they
wanted to bury the hatchet but when one
of the black fires arrived to treat with
the Great Council he was arrested by the
gold cloaks and beheaded
so no hatchet being buried there the
black fires still hate the crown later
egg gave him the option of taking the
black he accepted so he went to the wall
within about six years of that he became
Lord Commander of the Nights Watch
so Brandon Rivers who was the Bloodraven
became part of the small Council then
handed the king then became Lord
Commander of the Nights Watch but after
about 13 years as Lord Commander of the
Nights Watch disappeared while ranging
north of the wall that was almost fifty
years before the events of what's
happening on the show right now so
presumably when he disappeared north of
the wall he was just embracing what he
thought was his path as the last
greenseer think of him as being like
Benjen stark before Benjen stark existed
although Benjen stark is not a green
seer you just go north of the wall one
day ranging disappeared never to be seen
again now I think I've said it before
but the interesting thing is is that
when he went to the wall rigidly when
Brynden rivers took the black went to
the wall he was also accompanied by
maester aemon who at the time took the
black because there were way too many
Targaryen heirs at the time maester
aemon was one of egg on the fifths
brothers he was originally chosen as a
candidate to become a future king during
that big Great Council but he ceded to
his younger brother egg so in previous
seasons when we heard maester aemon
talked to Jon Snow about duty to family
like when Jon here's what happened to
Ned Stark what's going on with Robb
Stark he wants to go help them a stream
is like I know exactly what you're going
through I had to watch the downfall of
my family at the hand of the Mad King
now that doesn't even begin to get into
greensight all the things that he's
going to be doing with bran Stark in
season six but just in case you're not
sure their skin changing and then
there's green side so the ability to
skin change is something that's passed
down genetically amongst people with DNA
from the first men it's it's like a
first men thing but I think the numbers
like 1 in every 1,000 people that are
born with the ability to skin change are
also born green seers that's also
genetic but you know being born a
skin-changer is a very rare thing the
chances of being born a green seer are
almost impossible so it's incredibly
rare that's why until brand comes along
the Bloodraven is called the last
greenseer skin changing just allows you
to quote unquote wear the skins of other
biological creatures greenside is a much
more broad spectrum power over nature
there's some really cool things that I
don't want to spoil ahead of season six
we might end up opening season six with
like a really special green site
sequence so stay tuned for that but if
you want to read more about brand
learning about green site in the
three-eyed Raven
then re-read Dance with Dragons that's
when most of those chapters happen
here's my big question for you guys let
me know in the comments do you think
that they're going to address this big
grand history that the Bloodraven has
had or do you think it's going to be
like they did with Maester Aemon where
he just references it like I have had to
witness a lot of very sad history in my
family there are a lot of shows that do
that like kind of brush over a lot of
history with a really simple turn of
phrase it says sometimes it is effective
sometimes it kind of sucks I think a
really good example of it is during the
flash season one when Barry's
confronting the reverse-flash and he
asked some flat-out why have you done
all this why are you trying to hurt my
family why do you hate me so much in the
reverse-flash really coldly just replies
it doesn't matter so be prepared for the
show and even the books for that matter
to not fully explain things most of the
history of the Bloodraven is covered in
the expanded materials like if you read
world of Ice and Fire and then you read
the Dunkin egg series like you hear
about a lot of things happening in and
around its life I think wins a winner is
going to be a really big book for that
character so odds are if we're going to
learn more about his history it's going
to happen in that book still crossing my
fingers on a late March early April
release on wins a winner well hopefully
it'll drop like right before season 6 of
Game of Thrones drops now
congratulations to last week's giveaway
winner blue sky you win a $20 Amazon
gift card be sure to private message me
on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact info what's going to
happen next is is we are like
dangerously close to viral trailer
territory
we got the teaser for jon snow last week
from HBO so just expect more cryptic
teasers in the next couple of weeks
first trailer though do not expect that
before February just in case you haven't
seen it I did a whole big video about
that Jon Snow teaser the HBO released
you can click here to learn all about
that and you can click here for last
night's mid-season finale from Walking
Dead thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you